[music] [music
]
holding Moschun, we defended the capital, did not
fall, went to Kyiv
and followed them All of Ukraine, I thank everyone who
made this possible to all our defenders, to all
our defenders
[music]
Staff Sergeant Barilyuk Yury Senior Soldier
Bezsmertny Oleksandr Soldier Bilousov
Mykola
Soldier Blyznyuk  Bohdan soldier Brazhnyk
Nikita Bursa soldier Yevhen junior
sergeant Haydabrus Sergey soldier Galba
Pavlo junior sergeant Golovko Oleksandr soldier
Drayuk Petro
becoming soldier Duynev Roman junior
sergeant Yevdokymova Angelina senior
sergeant Yemets Oleksandr
lieutenant Zinoviev Andriy